en revanche en russie mais la frontière
avec l'ukraine tout près de rostov sur
le don où se trouve là aussi pour france
24 elena volochine elena c'est une
veillée d'armes ce soit on peut dire que
en tout cas dans le donbass on est sur
le pied de guerre
oui en même temps c'est la fête et la
lier à saint donan base tout comme ici
de ce côté-ci de la frontière je ne
parle du dombass attention je parle bien
des régions contrôlées par par les
autorités loyal à moscou et du côté
ukrainien donc de la frontière est du
côté russe ici également je vais aller
faire un tour en ville tout de suite
après mon direct mais j'entends déjà dit
si des claques sont des gens qui crient
hourras des bouchons de champagne qui
sautent chez mes voisins à l'hôtel et
qu'ils sont
cette annonce est accueillie avec avec
beaucoup de joie de ce côté ci du côté
du monde russes elle était attendue
depuis très longtemps on le rappeler
tout à l'heure mais la russie a déjà
distribué 800 mille passeport dans ces
territoires et quelque 70 mille réfugiés
qui ont fui le regard de violence sont
arrivés ici côté russe disait que
effectivement il plaçait tous leurs
espoirs en la russie ils attendaient
cette reconnaissance depuis très
longtemps depuis le début du conflit en
2014 et d'ailleurs les gens ne
comprenaient pas pourquoi la russie on
n'avait toujours pas reconnu ces
républiques et les câbles qui lui avait
prêté allégeance